good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday happy
first day back from maternity leave hey
claude how are you doing nobody [ __ ]
cares how are you
i'm really good i'm so happy to be back
this morning was pure chaos like trying
to make this happen of course but you
know the plan
i'll tell you how my morning went but
like so far everything's on track harry
just fed at the breast and so i have as
much time as i'm going to have who knows
how much time that could be there will
probably be a lot of pauses throughout
if he's crying or something but i'm just
hoping that everything goes as smoothly
as it has been going this morning i woke
up and i pumped while i did my makeup
then he woke up and i fed him and now
we're toasting and so i'm just hoping
for
a great show which i feel like it's
going to be because i miss you guys so
much you're such a mom i fed him at the
breast
pet him at the breast yeah well this man
is so hungry yeah and i'm exclusively
breastfeeding and we are living i know
we're up to drop
dropped every drop counts i have a
feeling i know where he gets that hunger
from it's definitely our side of the
family um and i feel for him i know what
that's like and it's it's he's got a
long life ahead of him you know
yeah and i would love to be in studio
but i just can't leave the house for
that long due to the need to feed and i
am pumping multiple times a day but he
eats everything that i pump that day and
i'm using the hakka and he eats the haka
that day too i don't have one drop for
stash and i've been pumping two to three
times a day so hopefully we'll get to
that place but right now i am chained to
the home i just want your change of the
rhythm i just want to say um
so
unfortunately i was not allowed in the
hospital room which is upsetting of
course but of course you know your body
your choice but since then i do feel as
though i've gotten to see new parts of
you literally i mean the way you just
whip them titties out girl is just
stunning the way you're just always like
draining those nipples i've just really
been able to see
a very nude side of you and i'm really
excited about it because i'm your sister
but you feel like you don't really let
me see you naked no i'm not a naked type
of person and i always would have
thought that like i mean my preconceived
notions of breastfeeding are all out the
window yeah and i could do a whole
episode on breastfeeding at this point
because it has been a journey and i had
no idea that it was so physically
emotionally mentally taxing
i'm in like a decent place right now i
think my nips do hurt but it's been it's
been a wild ride
but i always thought i would be someone
when i breastfed that i'm like you know
what i'll be in private like i don't i
have no issue with people breastfeeding
in public but i i'm not even like nude
in front of my sister so like why am i
gonna whip my kid out yeah but now it's
like this man needs to eat bring out the
breast no a hundred percent and now do
you understand like
people who um
like okay so the first time i ever got
in trouble on the internet the first of
many was like years ago when i tweeted
like there's a woman breastfeeding in
the doctor's office like getting private
like i was like and the breastfeeding
community descended upon me as they
should as they should do you now
understand the sensitivities from the
breastfeeding community
i understand the sensitivities but i'll
never understand descending upon someone
who just like is saying something that
is different from what you think but i
also like don't you have no idea and
when you wrote that like you don't know
a [ __ ] about breastfeeding so it's just
like i was literally 14. like you
shouldn't have even cared what you
thought
i saw a breast and i was like
no i would have thought the same but now
like to me a boob is not a private part
it's not even like a you know a thing
other than like a it's a fork and a
knife it's a meal yeah 100 percent it's
a plate
it's a dish
that's all it is and you know what this
isn't my plate
this is harry's plate yeah so how he's
getting them titties good in case you
missed it um or if you're not on patreon
or you're not on instagram i gave birth
on february 13th which was crazy because
it was literally i went into labor
saturday night well it was sunday
morning because it was 1 30 a.m but i
hadn't fallen asleep yet so it was
really like saturday night for me and
our last show was the day before and it
really couldn't have worked out any
better no you podcasted until one day
before you gave birth and you're back on
the podcast a month after and if you're
not setting real unrealistic
expectations for women then i don't know
who is no i just want you to know like
this this is a facade because
everything else going on here is chaos
like i don't even think harry recognized
me today because he's like who's this
woman like looking so glamorous when all
i've seen around the house is a hot mess
yeah like who's this glamazon and
where's my wench
where's my cow
story it's up on the patreon we're not
going to get into all of that today
because we already did about like a
40-minute episode on the patreon like
how it all happened contractions water
breaking what i felt what was the worst
part what was the best part like it's
all there for you but just to um clear
the air because there were some rumors
you did not have an at-home water birth
i read that about you that you did i
read that you facilitated that you were
my doula but it's just crazy how rumors
start and you know what's crazy about
that rumor is that i heard that i
started it
you wish your dream i would do anything
to be your doula
you you say that but you're actually
like so chicken [ __ ] you know yeah no no
no like i cannot you can't experience
pain i don't even think you can be like
a round pain you don't like look at gory
stuff and i just don't know that you are
the type of personality that's needed in
the birthing room honestly yeah no i
feel like when i give birth like i don't
even want to be in the room no oh and i
said this on the patreon but when i was
going through labor like all i i mean i
was thinking about a lot of things but
one thing i was thinking about was what
parts of it claudia will be able to
handle and what parts like she's going
to have to find a way to skip over no
and i think that most of it sounds like
something i need to skip no yeah i know
no definitely um definitely concerned
about that for sure
yeah so
check all of that out on the patreon and
other than that it's been just like a
crazy it really feels like a month but
it also went by so quickly
but every week i mean every day is so
different people are always like how are
you doing i never know how to answer i'm
like good how are you
yeah no when i was i've done like five
shows since you've been on maternity
leave and every single time um
people come to me and they're like how's
jackie has baby harry i'm like you know
she's doing good like the usual she's
exhausted but like she's so happy that's
always what i say yeah and that's really
how i feel and like different times of
the day like when we have a successful
feeding you know he falls asleep like at
the boob and it's just like seamless and
then like we're just sleeping together
like those are beautiful moments other
times i feed him for 40 minutes and he's
still hungry afterwards and crying so
it comes in waves but it's it has been a
beautiful experience and i think it's
what i expected except definitely not
the breastfeeding part like that has
been
more challenging way different than i
expected yeah i didn't know that there
were so many challenges that came along
with it and that even if like you could
breastfeed and everything is like
working that it's still
you know a challenge and and then the
challenge arises every two to three
hours so it's like even if your nips are
raw like you got to get back in the game
no and really the only kind of
first-hand experience we have with
breastfeeding is olivia and olivia was
like a killer breastfeeder couldn't make
enough milk freezer full of milk kaler
literally is still breastfeeding and
she's like 100 years old like no she's
not still breastfeeding that was a joke
but like olivia had a really you know
knock wood easy go of it with the
breastfeeding yeah like there was always
a bottle for kayla when she wanted a
snack no their freezer was literally
like a farm i don't know when the farm
freezer starts i'm so excited so many
times i'm like you know what i'll start
thinking about like putting this in the
freezer but it's like this man needs
every drop yeah so
we're giving it to him but it's just
it's a wild ride and i really i don't
want to set an unrealistic standard
because like you've been here you've
seen it's not been
glamorous no not at all not at all but i
want to put my best foot forward with
the toasters and i'm just excited to
to enter toastlandia for an hour and a
half i know it's truly an escape
especially because we have so much to
catch up on i mean we're gonna do a fast
five it's not gonna be the fast five of
like what happened yesterday it's gonna
be the fast five of like the big [ __ ]
that's been going on i have been doing
episodes on patreon so if you're looking
for like really in-depth analyses of
like kanye's instagram posts that's all
available on the patreon today's gonna
be more at a glance which we love to do
here um and i'd like to ask you jackie
have you seen last night's episode of
real housewives of salt lake city i did
so i am officially all caught up on
television except i have omitted real
housewives of orange county because i
only have so many hours of free time in
my life right now and it just can't be
spent watching things that don't spark
joy
but for the first few weeks of
breastfeeding like i wasn't watching tv
while i breastfix i really needed to
like focus on the latch
and everything that was going on
everything's so precarious but this week
i've been like in a better place so i'm
able to like watch tv while i feed and
i've been able to catch up on like
literally everything and like last night
i woke up
how many times before like three i had
three feedings like in the night so
that's when i watched salt lake city was
actually perfect oh that's great okay
well i am obviously all caught up on
television too because i have no
children and i'm
free as a bird um and even i have not
caught up on real housewives of orange
county i really have and i have given up
on it
yeah uh some things have to go but
everything else i mean
what else is on new jersey
salt lake city summer summer house
i'm working on gilded age like i am
i'm there also i just want to give a
shout out because i want to give a shout
out to podcasts i obviously like you
know have a special place in my heart
for podcasting like it is my occupation
of choice but like there is no better
partner for breastfeeding media
medium than podcasts cause you really
like tv's not great because you want to
be able to focus on the latch and like
you wind up being able to focus on
neither but with a podcast like it goes
by so quickly it's so funny and i'm
actually so excited for you to be doing
the toast without me so many days a week
because i will be able to enjoy the
toast while i breastfeed so if any of
you are listening right now while
breastfeeding like you got this like
it's it's going to be great babies
loving what you're making compliments to
the chef
come run to the chef and speaking of
co-hosts yes this week we've got a great
lineup if you want to check out who's on
this week um check out our instagram
we're going to go moving forward at the
cadence of jackie joining once a week if
you want to do more let me know but i
have filled most of the next coming
weeks with some
sickening people and i don't want to
give any clues because i want actually i
am going to give one clue for one
particular person because i'm
unbelievably unbelievably excited for
this person but just know we have like
weeks of amazing co-hosts including one
person who does not like beachy waves
and that's all i'll say but you think
the girls in france are doing beachy
waves that's all that's all i want to
say okay i think i know who that is and
i'm so excited it's going to be unhinged
like you guys have no clue like so now
we're going to try and start off every
week with a monday with jackie but
depending on the co-host schedules and
also jackie's just like frame of mind or
just chuck and jive there will be five
episodes except for when i'm on tour um
speaking of i added a second show in
houston because the first one sold out
in 35 seconds so head over to
girlsnowjob.com tour for your tickets
and of course we haven't even been on
the air sorry to like make now about my
no i was about to ask you i was about to
ask you how is your maternity leave
you know what it was so [ __ ] busy it
flew by all so i was gone for like three
out of four of the weeks but the first
week that we were on maternity leave
where you were like actually having a
child and i was actually doing nothing
was so glorious like i just maternity
leave without the child is really
something more people should do
i agree but also give yourself credit
you were doing the lord's work you were
watching bryce oh i was everybody wants
to know how that went
you know what i'm not gonna lie like i
was really um like not into the idea
even though it was my idea the second i
offered it i was like why did i do that
like i just i saw vacation bryce we all
went away for the holidays and bryce was
on vacation and he was not acting like a
good dog should so i was like oh my what
have i just invited into my home
and i was kind of dreading it like the
entire time leading up to
him being scooped up at my house i do
want to i just say that um and it was
the most
glorious what was it like eight or ten
days
yeah it was
sunday night or monday to third to the
following thursday yeah exactly it was
incredible like the love i have in my
heart for bryce is unmatched he's such a
good angel boy he loves his mummy and
his auntie and we like
it was just an energy match like he and
i were kindred spirits theo i think
towards the end was like can we get this
stranger out of our home but i loved and
like when it was time for zach to come
pick up bruno because i was going to
florida for tour um i was like low-key
like depressed like i was so sad
bryce will do that to you and i know you
didn't have faith in rice but i knew
that bryce had faith in himself and he
was gonna show you and i knew it was
gonna be a magical time for you i
actually didn't expect it to go as
amazingly as it did i figured he would
like take some time to adjust but no he
fit right in he had the most amazing
time and honestly when he came home like
i missed him so much when he came home
he had no time for me we needed like one
or two days to reconnect while also like
there is this new person in the house
and he's trying to like
adjust mentally in place
now he has settled into the big brother
role he's so curious about like you know
and every once in a while he's like
sniffing around especially when we're
breastfeeding but then he like settles
right next to us and it's so beautiful
and he's just really become a
responsible
loving big brother and he's also like
really territorial of me like if harry's
ever like sleeping and so i'm alone like
he wants to be curled up like a little
baby fed with a bottle and put into the
crib and swaddled does he try and get at
the rest
yeah oh yeah he's so
interested in what's going on there
could you i couldn't imagine anything
more painful
oh breastfeeding i was gonna say can you
imagine being bruno going on a vacation
to your cousin's house and coming home
and being replaced and there's literally
this like
child latched at your mother's breast
no i think it's been a lot for him
especially think about where we were
like right before i gave birth like
bruno and i were attached at the hip
like attached at the belly
we couldn't be apart for more than
honestly an hour yeah like when i had to
go to my doctor's appointments like i
missed brew bryce on ice and brights on
ice and rise on eyes and rise on eyes
and rise on eyes and i just i love bryce
i was so grateful any time if you're
feeling overwhelmed like you know he's
always welcome at auntie's place
thank you so much it's actually is so
good to know and
i will perhaps use that going forward
and i just want to thank theo for being
so accommodating and selfless during
this time
he's a selfless king
as the big cousin in the group as the
number one guy in this group that's what
he does
yeah it's very true
um so what else do we want to recap i
mean i've been going 100 miles an hour
and i have probably met in the last
month a thousand toasters like i not
only have i think i did five shows since
we
wrapped with five meet and greets but
also ben and i and brian have been going
around you know spritz is now in total
wines in florida almost i think all of
the locations and um total wines and
bevmos in all of california so that's
been really huge and when i was in
florida and when i was in california for
tour we did these like little pop-up
meet and greets and i met like thousands
of toasters it was incredible and
everyone got to try spritz for the first
time so a lot has happened in the last
month like spritz is like kind of like
changing the world um and don't forget
to use code toast at spritsociety.com
totally don't forget to do that and i
have a spritz to celebrate the return of
the toast i'm so happy for the toasters
that we're back like everything
exactly it should be
you know it was definitely you know hard
to be away but
you know absence does make the heart
grow fonder and i do think you know
of course i say this all the time like
you do the show every day sometimes it
feels like you're just like shouting
into the void but going off for a month
and seeing how like people like need
this show to live that was really nice
and we only heard that because we were
on maternity leave so i just think like
while it was torture it was nice to know
like people still watch the show
yeah and nice to know that we were
missed and i think we're all just like
really feeling grateful for the toast
today
yeah i think we all love the toast
i mean speaking of nickelodeon speaking
of nickelodeon speaking i um
this friday on the toast i'm sure you
guys already know josh peck from drake
and josh and the vlog squad is joining
me to co-host he's promoting his book
which i have gotten into i started
reading it and i was like gonna finish
it and i'm like i have to talk about
this in a week so i held off on like
this the second half i'm gonna finish it
this week right before he comes on it's
such a good book i actually think it
comes out tomorrow um and i think that
like everyone should try and get it and
read it before he comes on because it's
really in-depth and i'm not going to go
hard he's going to host with me but then
on the second half of the show i want to
do like a full book recap with him it's
such a good memoir like really good
okay i'm so excited to read it you said
such good things and i do have a bit of
reading time in my schedule i started a
book a few weeks uh like two weeks ago
it's taking me a while but it's like the
perfect thing to do when um like harry
falls asleep on me and i don't want to
like make a lot of noise because it's so
precious
so i will add that to my book cycle
and speaking of books you know really
good it's never too late to become a
redhead
though you might want to skip this month
because the reviews for the book are
dastardly
oh really who chose it yes dana and
dana's never flopped before so she's
allowed
but the dana's in her flop era
the worse the book is the better the
episode is so that's true you know it's
a give and take it feels like very hard
to just jump right in right now i just i
don't feel like
i don't feel like it's time but i don't
know what more i can like is there
anything else you want to talk about i
mean i have a million things i want to
talk about i mean i need to we need to
obviously do like a patreon episode just
about like the first month and all the
ins and outs and like taking people's
questions and such because i i've been
getting like so many questions about you
know
how things are going
but oh i just also wanted to give one
other shout out to something that i
watched i started watching it like two
days before i went into labor and then i
was watching it like the first three
weeks like when i had a time and that is
the show ladies of london
i can't even tell you how incredible the
show is i don't know why i decided to
rewatch it it's three seasons of utter
perfection
and it was so i like it was such a joy
to have in my life and i was like
looking forward to it so much like when
i'm pumping like that's what i would
watch and if you're looking for just
like premium content that show it just
lives rent-free in my mind now
the show is really like a moment in time
yes and it was filmed like six years ago
but it's as relevant as ever and also
now that like i've just been like so
into british history like the things
that they do in the places that they
went like obviously mapperton is it's
it's a
character but like every episode they're
doing something so fabulous like going
to castles going to scotland going to
denmark like there's so much history
there it's an amazing show i just like
needed to shout that out and you know
what's so funny about mapperton is i
feel like um ever since watching the
crown i too have been like you know not
as much as you like just dabbling in
british history and some of the
documentaries i watch on
like stuff julie is in every documentary
she's like a royal expert in everything
no yeah she her brand now is like the
american vi countess and she has like a
patreon and a youtube channel where she
like tours different patreon a patreon
she tours different like uh stately
homes
and where we were watching something i
guess it was yes when we were on
vacation we were watching a documentary
on high clear the real house in downton
abbey and they just had all these
different experts talking about like
what it's like to maintain these homes
how much you know it costs et cetera and
she was like one of the royal experts
yeah which is a great path for her but
after watching ladies of london again
i'm just like i have no i have no time
for her and it's also making me so
excited for real housewives of dubai
because of caroline stanberry
i mean caroline stanberry is a queen
like
everything of the sort everything
everything of the sort ins it was insane
so if you're looking for just something
good to binge watch that's like mindless
but also like quite mindful
ladies of london that's my time in the
day
season one ladies of london caprice like
that was truly like an iconic moment
that most people will never get to
experience again for the first time you
know yeah and then she was just like
swiftly never to be seen or heard from
again
no like is she okay
i know and i was finishing season one
when i went into labor and that's when
like caprice goes into labor she's
having one um child
no like so she had hired a surrogate and
then like a month later got pregnant
naturally so she was having two kids
within a month of each other and like as
she's go like talking about being
dilated and stuff i'm like oh my gosh
like i'm dilating it was just like very
simpatico
you and caprice
kindred spirits kindred spirits
so i guess with that we can jump right
in and you know maybe i'll remember
things that i just wanted to share i
feel like every time something happened
i'm like i gotta talk about this on the
toast well run off show for today is
we're going to do the past five little
tv recap the finale of the worst season
of housewives of all time real
housewives of salt lake city season two
we'll recap and then it's monday which
means our unburden yourselves segment is
on it's actually only our second time
ever doing the segment because we did it
once and then we went on maternity leave
so unburden yourselves is our monday
segment where you can write in and tell
us something you did over the weekend
that you just need to get off your
shoulder and therefore unburden
yourselves um we've got three unique
ones um and if you ever want to submit
it's unburden yourself
plural unburden yourselves we couldn't
get the email on burden yourself so it's
unburden yourselves
at gmail.com
great and now i guess without further a
do
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
yes and today's episode is brought to
you by the solo stove upgrade your
backyard with a solo stove fire pit it
is the perfect catalyst for getting
outside and spending more time with
family and friends you can build lasting
memories around a solo stove fire pit
solo stove is literally the only way to
make a fire pit we live in apartments
and we still have one for any time we go
on vacation it's smokeless it's so easy
it's like super easy to transport if you
don't have a fire pit in your backyard
and you want to get one this is actually
a really um affordable way to do that
and it's just engineered the best way
because it's made with premium grade 304
stainless steel and it has a 360 degree
airflow system that maximizes the
efficiency and minimizes the smoke so
you don't have to be sitting there
getting smoke in your eyes being like
this is great when it's not it's easy to
light
with just a few bits of starter and then
your fire is blazing in minutes it's
perfectly portable you could take solo
stove with you on camping trips and more
so whether you live in an apartment or a
house it's just great to always have um
we've used it many many times and we're
city dwellers and if you have a backyard
like highly recommend it's just everyone
wants a fire pit but there's like no
reason to get like this really expensive
one that like always breaks a solar
stove is everything of the sort it's
portable you can bring it in you can
leave it outside it's great and you can
shop now and get up to 30 off fire pits
all month long when you use the promo
code toast at checkout to get a 20
coupon so they're having a 30 off month
long fire pit sale and then you can get
an extra 20 off when you use code toast
they also offer a lifetime warranty and
free 30-day returns so it's
simple
go to
solostove.comsolostove.com and remember
to use code toast to get that 20 off
solo stove
do it
today's episode is also brought to you
by liquid iv which has been a
life-saving product for me um in this
last month going on tour a million times
going on many benders i was in vegas it
was a journey liquid iv is everything
you need because staying hydrated is
really hard
one goal i personally have for myself is
to be you know
more
take better care of my mind body and
spirit and we're gonna be doing that
with the help of our favorite hydration
product liquid iv so one stick of liquid
iv goes into 16 ounces of water and it
hydrates you faster and more efficiently
than water alone because it contains
five essential vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and
vitamin c there's um endless uses for
liquid iv i think obviously for me
personally being hung over is a great
time to use liquid iv um but there's a
million times and just like being
hydrated throughout the week is so
important you can really feel the
difference in like your mind your
clarity um
and like what i'd be super easy it's
very time efficient because it's just
way faster than drinking water it's
super effective and they're on a mission
to change the world they've donated over
19 million servings globally so grab
liquid iv in bulk nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use the code toast so
that's 25 off anything you order when
you use promo code toast at
liquidive.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidive.com
promo code toast
great thank you
now it's a pleasure
for our first story category is the
kardashians everything that has happened
literally even in like the last 48 hours
obviously we're not talking about like
kanye and julia fox breaking up because
that's old news and it's all been
recapped on the patreon if you're
looking for that right but there are a
number of things that we're going to get
to and we just want to list them off so
i don't forget
when first we're talking about the text
between kanye and pete that were shared
yesterday the photo of pete the tattoo
kim etc then we need to talk about kim's
quote about working hard and all of the
backlash that that has sparked
then we need to talk about wolf webster
because kylie shared the name of her
baby boy like literally two hours after
we finished the last episode of the
toast and i have so many thoughts i have
so many thoughts that i need to share
and then this morning the hulu extended
trailer for the show the kardashians
dropped and there is so much in there
so let's start from the beginning
kanye pete ever since we went off the
air kanye is still on instagram still
you know sharing his truth letting
everyone know how he feels when he feels
it and yesterday he shared text messages
from pete davidson i'm going to read
them to you pete said yo it's skeet that
is you know kanye's name for pete he
said can you please take a second and
calm down it's 8 a.m and it don't got to
be like this kim is literally the best
mother i've ever met what she does for
those kids is amazing and you are so
[ __ ] lucky that she's your kid's mom
i've decided i'm not going to let you
treat us this way anymore and i'm done
being quiet
grow the [ __ ] up and kanye wrote back oh
you using profanity where are you right
now and pete took a screenshot a selfie
of him in bed and said in bed with your
wife
okay i just have to say like
i'm obsessed like
beyond
yeah i mean they're so they also like
made their relationship like instagram
officials sort of like she posted a
carousel of photos
he's he she took a big dump and he's in
two of the pictures she is no longer kim
kardashian west her divorce has been
granted her name has been changed on
instagram and like she is moving i don't
think her divorce has been granted i
think she's been legally categorized as
single
right is that not a divorce granted like
how no the law is occurring the law is a
reason for you i was gonna say that's
true
that's for damn sure that's for damn
sure
so she is just like foraging ahead in
this new era of her life and i think you
know the last few months have been
frustrating with kanye and it seems like
she's at a point now where she's like
i'm not going to tiptoe around him
anymore this is my new man and also like
kanye's not tiptoeing around her like he
was out with julia he has a new lady in
his life and he's due like he's more
public with his relationships than kim
is right now it's just like they don't
seem as stable as kim's
no i think kim and
pete by proxy have reached this point
where like they have it's been a month
now a month that they have tried to
handle everything privately never once
say anything publicly about kanye handle
the whole thing with grace and just
really try and keep it like within the
family and now after a month it's
abundantly clear that that's not an
option for kanye so like why should kim
and pete let them like let kanye just
drag them on
um
what's the word like
without them responding like uncontested
uncontested like no [ __ ] and now we're
all playing like that okay and i loved
these text messages first of all
okay like i know i said this the last
time we were on
the air and everyone like disagreed with
me but like now even more like i'm kind
of feeling like kim and pete like might
be otp like of course the way he's like
defending his family and the way he
talks about kim as a mom like i was
actually crying what yeah you just
called kim's family his family it's
unclear even if he's even met the kids
yet because kanye was like saying a few
weeks ago like you'll never meet
the kids i think that that he has met
them because in the text messages he was
like i'll see you we can meet after
saints game like they were all going to
saints game oh [ __ ] okay that is yeah no
it's so crazy like today it is march
14th like they met in october that's a
long time
no and the tattoo
and the tattoo okay but like he gets
tattoos really of like so many of the
women that he hates which is why he has
so many tattoos right right so it's not
like as big of a deal for him as if like
you got ben's name tattooed on you which
i feel like at this point i'd be
comfortable doing like i'm in for the
long haul you know right right so like
yes it's surprising but also like i
think he probably with every tattoo he
gets he probably has a plan in place for
how he's gonna cover it up
yeah no it's like not a big deal when
you have that many tattoos like you just
turn it into something else i agree but
this whole saga just has really made me
respect pete so much i think those text
messages they're up on instagram like i
encourage everyone to like really look
into the i read them 55 times like
him saying us us us i was just unwell um
him like defending kim as the best mom
ever which we know her to be and like
it's and that's something she obviously
cares a lot about and i think that's why
this whole saga has gotten to her
because it's kanye critiquing her
parenthood
parenting and me and ben were actually
talking about this in bed last night
like about the tick tock thing and he
was like ben was saying you know i
actually kind of agree with kanye i
certainly don't want our kids on tick
tock i'm like no 100 but like it doesn't
even matter anymore what they're arguing
about because the manner in which kanye
has handled it is so atrocious and it is
borderline harassment that i don't even
care what they're fighting about anymore
kanye's wrong
yeah yeah the the message has been lost
whatever once was and there's also like
now all this like every day it's
something else and i haven't been
keeping up like i'm just tuning back in
now and the fact that it's still ongoing
is crazy it's crazy and they need this
can't last yeah and i guess like someone
could say like kim like this will just
be over if you take north off of tick
tock and like while that may be true
then you're just giving power to someone
like oh you're gonna bash all of us on
social media and then i'm gonna give you
what you want that's just not
that wouldn't be the smart thing to do
honestly
yeah but it's also like not just about
north on tick tock anymore like it's
about pete like he really yes but these
like bouts on social media are triggered
every time kanye sees a tick tock and
they just did this trend on tick tock
i'm in love with an emo girl it's a new
travis barker
machine gun kelly willow smith song it's
so good me and ben i've been like all
weekend i fell in love with an emo girl
i heard someone is an emo girl it's so
good i heard in kanye's video i didn't
watch all of them or the whole things
but he was like north singing i fell in
love with an emo girl
so it's such a good song
okay i'll have to check it out i'm so
behind all i listen to now music are
like songs that are going to come harry
um so i don't know oh so you're
listening to a lot of toast by claudia
i'm listening to a lot of claudia ashrae
um it's just the thing that's it's the
only thing that works kids love it
kids
kid-tested parent approved
okay so that's the ladies with kanye and
pete like and i'm sure it's not the
final and now like kim and don't get me
wrong wait i'm like sad that kim's going
through this but the fact that we got
these text messages like
as a result and we got to see like pete
standing up for kim i just
i was overjoyed
yeah and now we're gonna see like more
kim and pete also in the trailer for the
new hulu show let's just jump really
quickly because it came out this morning
and there's so many different story
lines that are happening but kim is
talking about pete and he it is very
much like part of the show
also travis and courtney are trying to
have a baby
yep tristan and chloe are there but it's
unclear like it doesn't seem like she
ever really took him back but who knows
what kylie is talking about her
pregnancy candle is storming away from
the table
scott is in it yes
it seems like kardashians but like i
feel like they're even pulling back like
one more layer and they were always like
showing us all of the layers but i think
that like there's probably a couple that
they have concealed over the years but
they're giving a little bit more of
themselves like for this hulu paycheck
yes and so i don't want to skip again
but
the variety article that she's getting a
lot of backlash about we'll talk about
that but in that interview what a lot of
people like are only talking about that
one thing obviously but they talk a lot
about how the style of this show was so
different it's very like documentary
vibes and you know towards the end with
e like e was trying to get certain
things they didn't say exactly what they
were talking about specifically but they
said you know he wanted different things
from the show and the way he wanted to
set up the show was very different and
you could tell like those stupid
gimmicks and like all these pranks and
then like these fights like it was like
fights and pranks it was so stupid um so
i actually think we're gonna like this
style of show
much better it seems like they're not
wasting our time also there's no
commercial so it's just like less
standard stupid show vibes you know
yeah i agree and they keep they kept
talking about in the variety article
like drone footage and i was like what
do you mean we always get like an
overshot of the house but then when i
said the whole show was on drones right
then i saw the trailer and it's like the
drone zooms into chris's office yeah and
so that's pretty cool and i'm sure it's
also easier to become not that they're
not comfortable around the cameras but
instead of having like all of these
people holding cameras around you like
if it's just a drone like it's easier to
just be real like more natural it also
seems like they talk directly to the
camera
while they're filming like
it's not just we only hear from them
they're confessionals yeah it seems like
it's more of like breaking the fourth
wall it looks so [ __ ] premium i ca
and it's dropping in a month i honestly
can't wait and like i somehow ended up
on the kardashians on hulu pr list i
don't know if you saw my stories i did i
got this like big box that said
kardashian's on hulu and it was like
filled with gorgeous things that's so
gorgeous they're doing a lot of promo
like so
a month feels like really far away like
for the amount of press that they're
doing like it should be dropping this
weekend yeah i would love to see kim on
snl again like i know it was only a year
ago but like
the new show
yeah maybe she'll go back because she
has the inside track right even though i
did watch this week's snl it was
atrocious and pete was not in it for one
minute
because he's busy in l.a yeah and pete
actually just got a new movie deal with
lauren michaels it's gonna be like a
comedy about his life which i feel like
um every movie he does is like a
dramatized version of his life like
didn't we just watch king of staten
island which was literally about him
yeah and then the other one like big
brother
the one where he's like a big camper
yeah like he does he's already done this
movie right we watched it for toast
movie of the week remember
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah big counselor
stuck at home yeah adult adult life
something
[Laughter]
big adults
little dumb
something like that and machine gun
kelly was in it yeah yeah
and machine gun kelly was also in staten
island
i didn't watch staten island because i
saw a big adult and that was enough for
me big adolescence
big big time adolescence
got it we were so close big adults so
close little kid
um
now we can talk about the variety
article like i hate that this moment got
over like overshadowed the whole thing
because it actually was a really
interesting video to watch i mean
whoever was doing the lighting in the
video like did the girls absolutely no
justice um
but obviously what everyone's talking
about is
seems like nobody wants to work these
days get your [ __ ] ass up and work
yes so kim shares a quote about i guess
it's advice for you know how to succeed
in business she said no women in
business women yeah she said i have the
best advice for women in business get
your [ __ ] ass up and work it seems
like nobody wants to work these days
and this has sparked like a ton of
backlash um
of course because kim is a billionaire
now she's got nannies and assistants and
chefs and trainers so it's easy for
someone in that position to be like get
your ass up and work someone who doesn't
really live in the real world
and as a lot of people pointed out was
born in beverly hills and yeah i don't
think that takes away from her work
ethic but it definitely puts you in a
position of privilege with access to
things and so while it was definitely an
out of touch thing to say
i do know what she was trying to say
which is definitely like we live in this
culture and it's like the stereotypes
about millennials is like millennials
don't work and we like i know what she
was trying to say but it was like not
the vibe
yeah i mean i have a lot of thoughts
about this first of all i think like the
most outspoken critic was jamilah jamil
and this is what she said she said i
think if you grew up in beverly hills
with us with super successful parents in
what was simply a smaller mansion nobody
needs to hear your thoughts on success
slash work ethic this same 24 hours in
the day [ __ ] is a nightmare 99.9 percent
of the world grew up with a very
different 24 hours i so completely agree
i just want to say one thing about jamil
jamil because i love her so much she's
like been one of my role models but
she's always coming for the kardashians
and she comes for women a lot and it's
just like i get and i think her points
are valid but it's like i'm just more of
a type of guy who lifts each other up
you know
yeah i mean when i read this variety
article and i read that quote like it
did not stand out like and i saw the
video too and it was like before there
was backlash it was like share it as
like you know some like an empowerment
thing get your [ __ ] ass up and work
and it didn't like strike me as anything
other than like just promoting hard work
which is a
value that i think is valuable and then
seeing all of these different
perspectives i'm like okay yeah if you
look at it like that like you could be
offended by it but i just think in
general like all she's saying is like
work hard and not necessarily like do
people who work hard have success and
people who are successful sometimes
don't even work hard like there are
other factors that go into having
success but i think in general just like
promoting the concept of like hard work
hard work isn't a bad thing isn't it it
shouldn't be a controversial thing i
think you know if you're going to like
dissect the quote i mean i guess they
must have asked her like what is your
advice for women in business that was
the question
because this should just be advice for
anyone in business like right not just
women but they asked her for women
specifically no and you know what like
it's easy to poke fun at this answer
because like it is a little cringe but
you know
so i made this instagram reals like
about this particular um video it was
like very funny i mean it got over a
million views feel free to check it out
and my god the comments like
holy [ __ ] every comment is like yeah
well i don't want to have a sex tape so
i have to work hard sex tape sexy sex
tape and i just got done watching pam
and tommy which was incredible by the
way um and you really see like the
the consequences of having like your sex
tape leaked especially as a woman like
for pam anderson it was like
so horrifying and so detrimental to her
career whereas like tommy lee was a rock
star who took his dick out at concerts
like it didn't have as much of an effect
on him um so just having seen that and
then see like everyone be like sex tape
thanks hey really there's plenty people
have a sex tape who don't have a three
billion dollar company so like kim does
know a thing or two about how to build
business and maybe how she built her
business is by non-stop hard work so
that's her experience i don't think we
can devalue that just because she did
grow up in a privileged lifestyle which
definitely gave her easier access to it
yeah let's not forget she's faced many
challenges 100 but also there are so
many people who are born into privilege
who completely squander like every
opportunity who do nothing who create
nothing who end up in jail and yeah like
there are so many different especially
like in the hollywood world like
there aren't that many kim's out there
and i think what separates her from even
just like a moderately successful
celebrity is her work ethic
when you think about all the things that
she does and you could say like well
yeah you know my work ethic would be
strong if i was just like posting to
instagram too and it's like she's like
not what she does for a living it's not
what she does for a living like
obviously she has all of these
businesses she's also a mom she's also
like elected to become a lawyer like
she wakes up at literally 5am like her
business is so much like her body and
her looks and she spends time two a days
in the gym like this woman is working
hard and that's her advice to other
people like i think they're if you want
to you know
break it down and be offended by it like
go off i just think it wasn't that deep
for me it's just like you want to be
successful work hard isn't
something that i think we should all
be against yeah no i agree i i but i did
watch it and like cringe a little bit um
but it is good advice like hard work
will always pay off
yeah no i think like a good work ethic
is something that we should be striving
for i agree right it's not like
something that's like
that we should look down on yeah yeah
i agree i mean i'm all for equality but
like on the last show i think that was
like a source of a lot of the
anger like especially as it pertained to
courtney where it's like we're all
getting paid equal money but we're not
contributing equal amounts of work so um
i agree and courtney is like so
interesting now that she's the most
interesting to look at that i'm actually
really um
praying for her to be an equal part of
the pie but that also goes for kendall
and kylie yeah no i honestly it makes
chris it makes me think of kendall and
kylie more because even though courtney
was always complaining like she was
there and she was showing up and i have
i can't imagine kylie was getting paid
for those last seasons when she was not
on and i also think for courtney like
being in this season of her life like
when you are happier you are there you
want to share these things like when
like there was so much that she didn't
want to share and so it just really
siloed her and i imagine she's just like
let you can even see on her instagram
like yeah she's in a sharing state of
mind yeah i agree and i think the
revelation that they want to have a
child was like so shocking to me it just
didn't occur to me because they both
already have like big families um and i
my first thought was like oh my god that
must be crushing for scott
oh no my first thought was like i
couldn't believe that they were sharing
it with us considering there's been all
this speculation like every time she
steps out like yeah like she's pregnant
right and they're just gonna like take
us on this journey with us and like be
so open about something that is so
private private yeah no i agree i'm
really happy for them and now i'm like
really equally excited to see every
single sister they all i mean of course
kim always chloe is the best courtney
has this like whirlwind romance kylie's
pregnant and kendall i feel like we
literally know nothing about yeah like
what's she been up to and she's like you
know been sharing more about her
relationship maybe we'll hear more about
it probably yeah i would love to
a girl can dream yeah
so
there's a lot of exciting things on the
horizon for the kardashians now we are
45 minutes into this episode pretty much
and we're still on story one oh wait no
there's more [ __ ] sorry there's more
kardashian [ __ ] we need to talk about
wolf webster because um i have so many
thoughts
and
on friday when we wrap the show kylie
posted to her instagram i okay i know
this is crazy and it's probably not true
but we dropped the episode like two
hours before she posted and i had said
like i just really am dying to know
kylie's name
and when you're pregnant and
breastfeeding and like postpartum like i
do think podcasts are a wonderful medium
and i think that there's a chance that
kylie heard what i said and then she put
it out there for me okay you know me i'm
as delusional as an ex-girl and i just
think that that's not true
i think it's i really think it's
possible like imagine she's like
perusing for podcasts she goes she likes
a little bit of comedy she goes over to
the comedy section this is what i've
been doing i've been like looking for
podcasts so like i go to like the
episodes and like we're always up there
like there's a chance that she has
become a toaster in the last few months
i don't think kylie's out here listening
to podcasts about pop culture like she
lives in pop culture
that's true i wonder what her interests
are she probably listens to stuff about
like aliens true crime yeah like [ __ ]
normal people listen to damn well kylie
if you're listening give me a sign yeah
okay how about that kylie if you are
listening to this podcast which i know
that you're not
post something on your instagram okay
today about nature
or post a picture like of your manicure
if you have one because it's manicure or
like trees
okay what a gorgeous day in calabasas
except that she just posted this morning
she's getting on a plane and she posted
a beautiful sunset so i'm sure she has
her nails done for the trip please post
a picture of your manicure or she could
post the sunrise like you know what i
mean yeah okay so she posted that she
named her son wolf webster and i love
the nature and i promise you for about
an hour zach and i were here and like in
the family chat like thinking about wolf
wine rib it was never
number it was never like going to be his
name but like we didn't really have a
second choice for a name and like by the
time i gave birth like wolf was was my
number two
i completely agree i love the name
especially like wolf webster wolf wine
red like i like the uh alliteration um
i love the name and i loved it for you
too and i was like fully supportive of
changing harry to wolf
yeah except like he's such a hairy he's
so not a wolf especially in some lights
like he does have a little strawberry in
his hair and he's literally prince harry
he is prince harry he there's nothing
wolfy about him so it was never going to
suit him i don't know i've seen him i've
seen him at that breast it's pretty
wolfy
i feel like a lot of people did not like
the name wolf
that was a consensus that i was seeing
but it's one of if not my favorite of
the kardashian name so far i completely
agree because it's like a con it's not
common but it's not uncommon
it's like it's not stormy stormy right
it's not actually i guess like there was
like stormy daniels is the only other
stormy that i've heard of and that's
just a great legacy
namesake but um
wolf like other people common people
have named their kids wolf recently yeah
yeah yeah no it's not unheard of
yeah so i just thought it was a
beautiful name and i needed to share
that and i needed to let you guys know
that like wolf wine rib was on the table
almost
not even almost but like
we really all had a conversation about
it we all agreed it's not the name but
there was a conversation
a conversation was had you're right
so i just wanted to share that with
everyone and then of course i was like
oh my god when i do give birth i need to
post wolfliner up to my story and that
was just like really funny i'm just like
such a comedian
you're hilarious
okay let me check my list and make sure
we've gotten through all the kardashian
talking points and we have
great we are we are ready to move on
it's time to move on it is time to move
on are you ready for our next story if
it's a story that's brought to you by
honey
it is well thanks to honey manually
searching for a coupon code is a thing
of the past because honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart here's how it
works imagine you're shopping at one of
your favorite sites and when you check
out the honey button drops down and all
you have to do is click apply coupons if
you wait a few seconds honey will search
the coupons it can find for that site
and then if they find a working coupon
you just watch the price drop it's free
to download there's literally no reason
not to have honey it works at so many
websites i've used it for makeup
clothing food electronics like all my
favorite websites use honey um and they
even offer cash back at thousands of
stores so it's basically like earning
cash rewards just for shopping if you
don't already have honey you are
straight up missing out and by getting
it you're doing yourself a solid and
supporting the toast because we would
never recommend something we don't use
and we've been using honey since before
we even started the toast so you can get
honey for free at joinhoney.com
toast that's
joinhoney.com toast free to download
save yourself time and money
love it thank you so much our next story
is actually news from yesterday haley
bieber confirms that she suffered
stroke-like symptoms due to a blood clot
so following reports that she was
hospitalized this week haley bieber
clarified on social media that she
suffered stroke-like symptoms due to a
small blood clot in her brain she posted
on thursday morning i was sitting at
breakfast with my husband when i started
having stroke-like symptoms and was
taken to the hospital they found i had
suffered a very small blood clot to my
brain which caused a small lock of
oxygen but my body had passed it on its
own and i recovered completely within a
few hours although this was definitely
one of the scariest moments i've ever
been through i'm home now and doing well
and i'm so grateful and thankful to all
the amazing doctors and nurses who took
care of me
that is
so scary like
no blood going to no oxygen going to
your brain for like a couple seconds
so scary um it reminds me a little bit
of like what happened to kim zolciak but
she had an actual stroke years ago
oh when she was super young a blood clot
i don't know what it was but it was just
like you don't hear about young people
having strokes it's like not common
yeah no this was it definitely
incredibly scary and shocking and um i i
mean i'm glad she's doing okay but that
really can like
is a crazy like young healthy knock on
wood yeah and something like this
happens no it's so scary um and like
just to have it happen sitting at
breakfast like a totally normal day i'm
sure justin was there like that is so
freaky um and i can only imagine how
like scary it was if she was alone you
know
oh my god yeah yeah like that's just
like something that
is so bizarre i hope she can find out
this feels like one of those like
mysterious ailments that people spend
like months and years trying to figure
out like what happened i hope she can
find like the cause of what happened to
her yeah well it's not like a mysterious
ailment like you know i always when i
think of mysterious elements i think of
um lyme's disease no i think of the show
royal pains because they were always
just like oh like houses yeah and house
too like where it's like it's blah blah
blah right there's only one reported
case in america in the last 50 years
yeah and it's like only this doctor can
can put it all together mm-hmm um but no
i mean it's very clear like what
happened she suffered a blood clot but
like from what
right no exactly and especially like
someone of her age
like there needs to be an understanding
at least for her of what right what
caused it
right 100
i'm really like sending her love i l
haley bieber has turned into one of my
favorite celebrities in the last three
years um like the way i would take a
bullet for her like i just died like i
died for her yeah no i totally agree
she's really she's grown on me like in
such a steady way that i don't see it
ever turning because it's not like it
was this like burst and sometimes things
that burn quickly you know jewelry
they burn out too but like she has just
been putting in the work for years now
of of stanhood of a ship for her and
justin like if those two break up i'm
like i i don't i
i really don't think that they will ever
break up no and i think also what makes
me like her so much is like
just by being herself and being married
to justin like she has put herself at
like the center of one of the most toxic
fandoms in the history of pop culture
and she's never once like addressed it
or leaned into it like she just lives
her life i'm sure it has to bother her
that there are so many people like every
time she gets paparazzi it's like selena
selena gelena jillian like i can't it's
so toxic and so weird like they're
literally married and they have been for
years like [ __ ] off yeah but i when i'm
on tick tock i see these like jelena
accounts like oh look at this picture of
haley and justin justin's thinking about
haley like i mean justin's singing about
selena shut up like shut up and she just
handled the whole thing with like the
utmost grace and elegance and that
cannot be easy so like that's part of
the reason i like stand really hard yeah
i always forget about justin and selena
but then you always remind me because
like you see the jelena stands on
tick-tock i don't and since you brought
up selena like i just want to say she's
been absolutely crushing it like on
every red carpet she presented at the
sag awards which i wound up watching a
lot of and they were yeah i don't know
why i think it was because i watched the
movie house of gucci
um and i watched oh i watched the eyes
of tammy faye and
oh my god i watch the eyes of tammy faye
also okay i watched it on the plane and
the plane ride home was so quick i still
have 25 minutes left like they just did
that interview
um
like where when after everything blows
up okay yeah the last 25 minutes um they
do drag it out they love to do that
and i had a lot of thoughts i mean it's
a crazy story i loved it by the way
there was something about it that just
like didn't
connect for me i can't explain it like
the like the quality of the movie like
it felt just like sometimes with these
like you know real people and we're just
gonna like dress up like them and tell
the same story it just like feels like
theater i mean i know that it is theater
no it just doesn't feel like artistic i
can't explain it i thought jessica
chastain was incredible i mean
everything she does and it's clear like
she loves this woman and her story and
like took the job of telling tammy
faye's story so seriously because tammy
fay and i was like googling pictures of
tammy fan on the plane because i wanted
to see what she actually looked like and
there was this article like of a picture
of tammy faye and rupaul and it was like
how tammy faye became like an lgbtq plus
icon like it's clear that like jessica
chastain like either knew the story
before or just like found the role and
fell in love with tammy and like wanted
to do justice that's exactly what it was
i watched her on the red carpet and she
had been working on this for 10 years
she just and even she won for her role
and even in her speech she just like
talked about like this love that she has
for tammy and like how tammy was just
like this loving person so she clearly
did want to do justice for her and i
mean i can't even just watching the
movie like there was not a more trusting
you know open-hearted person who
couldn't even see like this monster no
you know she was
she was a believer
she was a good christian like she was
like i think i mean i'm not christian
but it's like exactly what the bible
tells you to be like kind to everyone
like she was a good christian and that
made her like extremely vulnerable and
like open to people taking advantage of
her like that scene where andrew
garfield is like making fun of her with
his friends like i wanted to die like
that was so sad
so sad no it was a great movie i'm so
glad that you watched it too and then i
watched house of gucci which was also a
pretty good movie except for the fact
that i'm sorry to say i know what you're
really saying lady gaga ruined it yeah
no i actually have heard similar
sentiments it just wasn't seamless you
know
like you were just constantly aware of
who she was i want to say jared leto
like was the most amazing part of the
movie you should watch it it was a story
that i did not know so you don't know
how it's gonna end and it was uh i mean
it's a crazy story but
she did not i mean if she if she wins
any awards for it like that's just not
well she was snubbed for an oscar um
even though
i don't know if it's like a snub if you
didn't deserve it
um you know i don't think
i just want to say like if if there
wasn't all this like oscar buzz around
it like she wouldn't be held to such a
high standard you know every time she's
they're like will she become an egot and
it's like it doesn't have to be that way
so if she's just like acting in like if
we're just looking at her as acting in a
movie like it was fine but like there
was nothing oscar worthy about it um and
spencer okay spencer was literally the
movie jackie
because first of all it takes place over
like three days at i think it was
sandringham i think for christmas
um and i just hate movies that focus on
like one specific period in time i still
also have 20 minutes left because the
flights were so short so i need to
finish both of these movies so i don't
know maybe the movie's longer than those
three days at christmas i don't think so
um and to be honest like i did not think
it was good first of all like i don't
know what diana was like in person but
if she was anything like kristen stewart
then i would have [ __ ] hated her like
the way she talked like chrissy made her
so annoying and the movie actually makes
diana look terrible like
i don't know if
like if that was the point but it made
diana look like
bad
should i watch it
no i don't think i like it i want a
movie about the whole story
and i just want to say
airlines literally airlines don't get
enough credit like they had all these
oscar movies that like some that are
still in theaters like on united and
delta like i was so excited to be
watching tammy faye like that was just
i wasn't expecting such fresh gorgeous
relevant content on delta
yeah i'm glad that yeah we're so
relevant
movies they're keeping up look at us
oscar girlies
i'm sorry with the eyewitness news movie
minute
ebert roper
what the [ __ ] is that they're movie
critics they're critics you know what we
are jackie penn teller
okay are you ready for our next story
yes
it's some news about our favorite guy
elon musk and he is a father again
grimes is spilling the tea that they
welcomed a second second child secretly
in december so grimes um sat down for a
wide ranging interview with vanity fair
and she shared the news that her and
elon welcomed a daughter via surrogate
in december you know what's so funny is
um
she didn't really reveal
oh bruno he hears his auntie
like grimes didn't really reveal
anything she invited vanity fair into
her home to do
an interview and the baby started crying
and she was like oh i don't know why i
like assumed you guys could come here
and not know that there was a second
child upstairs so yeah we had a baby
yeah which is just so cute they're not
together right now were they together
when they
contacted the surrogate i would imagine
yes i mean that would have been well
more than nine months before december
because you know it takes a while to get
these things going um and ten months
because pregnancy is ten months so why
does everyone say nine months
right right so it's really like probably
over a year yeah and they were together
over a year i mean i imagine they were
together when they set out on this
journey and now they have um a daughter
which is just like so exciting exciting
news it is i always forget that elon has
like six other kids yeah he does he is i
think he's at eight now
so he has five other children from a
previous marriage seven and um that's a
lot of kids i mean i guess when you have
like unlimited wealth like you can have
as many kids as you want like it doesn't
matter
yeah and there's just like so much love
yeah in his heart to go around the name
of um their daughter is exa dark side
rail musk and they
they nicknamed her y which is actually
really cute because they have baby x
and y and then it's like x chromosome y
chromosomes
so
scientific i get it but like i can't
like i just can't what happened to sarah
what happened to matthew like i can't
yeah no i agree but like you know elon
and grimes are never going to be that
way so at least like they have x and y
like i can work with that no like i at
least i can understand it you know yeah
but like they keep using this symbol
where the a and the e are like
touching
yes unfamiliar how is that pronoun what
is that
um you are so asking the wrong girl i
have literally no idea
okay like i could just get clarity on
that i could
i could deal with the rest you know
i'm not i'm not the girl for the clarity
sorry
okay cool anyways they don't call me
they don't call me cleria
these two um that was i'm sad that i'm
sad they're not together but i'm glad
that they're the and she says like he's
her best friend like they are good
good i'm happy for them but like if you
love him so much like why not just be
together i hate [ __ ] like that like i
love you always with all my heart okay
so get married i think they'll get back
together but i say that about everyone
and then they [ __ ] hate each other
yeah totally la la you're the curse too
you're the curse lala and randall kim
and kanye
yeah so i'm just gonna say grimes and
elon i don't chip i hope they never get
back together perfect put that into the
universe we have to say it more
convincingly because i'm not believing
anything you're saying oh yeah no i want
to see elon and kim
honestly same yeah that'd be cute
are you ready for our next story yes
ma'am we could not
do today's episode without letting you
know that justice for jesse
was served the empire star was sentenced
to 150 days in county jail for staging
the hate crime and lying to authorities
so last week he was sentenced for
staging his own hate crime and filing a
false police report with the police a
little more than two months after the
jury convicted him on five counts of
disorderly conduct um
he did then have like some
like a breakdown in
in the courthouse basically telling
everyone that if anything happens to him
like please no he's not suicidal yeah
which honestly um
i'm glad that i know that now because if
anything does happen like now we know
now we know he said quote i'm not
suicidal and if anything happens to me
when i go to jail i didn't do it to
myself and you must all remember that
okay i mean a lot of people have been
talking about this like and i feel like
we've been talking about it forever like
do you think this is like
a fair
sentence like taraji p henson is on
instagram like
basically acknowledging like he lied and
made this whole thing up but like this
is you know a harsh sentence
oh is that what people are saying i
think people are divided um
what is it 120 days what is that four
months 150
five months
yeah a long time but like he did lie i
don't know like
i feel like you know lying to police and
like wasting police resources is like
something that we're always like
threatened with like on svu they're
always like you know lying to the police
is a crime i don't know if i remember in
recent memory of anyone actually getting
convicted for lying to the police and
wasting police resources yeah but also
like in such a big way you know i think
there's a difference between like
placing a 9-1-1 call you know that's
what you like are told when you're a kid
like you can't like that would be the
equivalent but
this was just like a whole
bigger thing investigation there was
like it went on for long how long did it
go on between when he you know called
the police and when everybody found out
that it was a lie like it was kind of a
few weeks
no like at least two weeks that's how i
feel like i remember it i feel like i
remember it being like a week maybe less
um
okay but you know my memory is literally
the worst on the planet so don't believe
it no no
i feel like it maybe could have been a
week i feel like it was like everyone
was talking about it and then like
slowly like people like stopped and then
one person was like what and then a
bunch of people were like oh my god he's
lying
yeah
so i don't know i feel like
you know me like i
i was ready for justice i don't know i'm
like
i don't know torah she's like getting to
me i'm like is this so would you have
like wanting to see less jail time or
like a sentence of community service in
a fine i don't know i'm just like
it just gets real like for me one of my
biggest
fears in life is going to jail so five
months in jail is like so much
yeah but also and like it's just to me
it's like a crime
but like he lied you know i lie all the
time you know not saying that i would
ever do this but you know what i mean
like it's to me i'm just now it's very
real
yes it is real but i think it's been
real what he was you know saying had
happened to him was
beyond real yeah you know
i just don't know how to feel like i
thought i would feel more excited i'm
like justice because we've been
following the story for so long what he
did is so egregious like it's so
horrible
um and the fact that he's still
maintaining his innocence is just beyond
me um
and now i'm just like oh my god five
months in jail like that's just a lot
yeah
well that's what it is for jesse so
the jessie saga is over that's what it
officially means
yeah yeah it is and that's crazy
and speaking of things that are not over
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
is it um about tom brady being such a
drama queen
drama queen of the nfl tom brady says
he's returning as tampa bay buccaneers
quarterback next season okay so
literally two months has it been not
even
since he you know made his big swan song
and let us know he's out the door he's
hanging up his jersey and now he said
these past two months where by the way
like no football was played he didn't
miss a game or anything no one was
really like oh i wish tom brady didn't
retire he's 41. like everyone like said
their wells but like his season was over
so he says this these past two months
i've realized my place is still on the
field and not in the stands but like
when were you in the stands at a time
when you could have been in the field in
the last two months
maybe like at practice
he said that time will come but it's not
now i love my teammates and i love my
supportive family they make it all
possible i'm coming back for my 23rd
season in tampa unfinished business
lfg which means let's [ __ ] go
oh thank you right grandma yes
um i do remember when we reported on his
initial retirement that like
i didn't really feel like he should have
went out on a loss like is the greatest
of all time you always want to go out on
top and i still firmly believe two years
ago when he won he should have retired
like he you know he said i came to tampa
i made a team out of this team and i won
the super bowl and that's why i'm the
greatest goodbye mic drop then he stayed
for another season and he lost so like
now he's just in this limbo place where
i feel like he's not going to retire
until he wins one more time
because he cares about his legacy i just
would have hoped that like he would have
thought that through before he made it
big stink
and now it's like he's the boy who cried
retirement the next time he tells us he
was retired nobody's gonna believe him
like i just feel like i feel like he's
being very wishy-washy with his legacy
he is and like
if you're gonna retire and come back
like
maybe give it a year two years and then
it's like he's back but like to give it
two months at a time when like there
were no football games that you missed
is just so dramatic you know it's like
nobody tom brady actually i'm not gonna
retire yeah no but also nobody tom brady
i'm retiring it's like nobody was like
waiting for you to retire either no i
don't i do think people were like
questioning like when his last season
would be just because he's at a certain
age that's it
yeah but he's still at the top of his
game i mean even though he didn't make
it to the super bowl like he's the best
quarterback in the league though i've
been overhearing a lot of pti and i
think aaron rodgers is the best
quarterback in the league and he just
signed the pti
it's a sports show pardon the
interruption that zack watches every day
i thought it was called pardon my take
that's the bar stool one got it got it
there's a lot of peas in sports
um
so aaron rodgers is apparently the best
quarterback in the nfl and also sidebar
he just signed the biggest contract ever
250 million dollars to stay with the
packers and him and shailene were
spotted together so like i i believe i
spoke about their breaking up on the
patreon episode and i was like utterly
devastated like i thought they were so
great together i'm devastated by the
news if they broke up i'm heartened by
the news that they're back together yes
i don't want to
put too much energy into it and just to
be disappointed and clearly they're on
shaky ground if there was another
breakup to begin with so it's like
that's not good um but i just love those
two and it just goes to show you how
like minds can be changed hearts can be
changed because when they first got
together we were like who in the what no
100
and i just feel like i really understand
shayleen woodley now when i started off
just not understanding her and her like
distaste for material items i hate
people like that yeah but then you know
she's with she just got back together
with him after a 250 million dollar
contract yeah by the way
no no but that's like so that's also
like grimes and elon grimes is like
anti-capitalism like
i see some of her tic tocs and it's like
money's evil like i don't know what her
entire philosophy is but it's like
i think it's like communist vibes i
think like she believes in like
communism and like shared wealth when
like she's literally having children
with elon the richest man on the planet
then it's like shailene woodley like
will not buy socks like she needs to
have her feet be grounded to the earth
but then also oh who's your partner the
highest paid uh footballer in the nfl
like i just can't with everyone and like
does nobody have
values principles like okay you don't
want you don't want someone who makes
250 million dollars a year fine i do
okay so [ __ ] off
no by the way answer to your question
nobody has values nobody's going to lose
no and they all claim to like grimes is
all principled about i'm sorry i'm not
really 100 sure what her philosophy is
but i know it's like very like new age
you know
um
economist i don't know but it's like
it's like hating the rich eat the rich
so literally like girl what are you
doing go date someone
you know who makes no money because you
hate money that's what you just said
yeah yeah but it's okay you know maybe
you don't have to date someone who has
no money but you're gonna date the
richest man on the planet right who has
become like the poster child
for money and capitalism yeah
right but maybe
conversely she loves him so much
that even you know it transcends values
like even though they are so different
they just can't help but be together i
mean it's possible
but um
i don't know i just think it's funny
that's also like what shailene reminded
me of like she's like this earthy queen
granola i remember reading an article
once like she disposed of all of her
material items like yadda yadda um okay
so
why are you dating someone who's 250
million dollars well that makes sense
then why she didn't wear shorts when
they went on that hike right now she's
anti-material items she's anti-material
yeah yeah exactly
okay well those were the fast five
stories i feel as though you needed to
know them and now you know i'm pushing
my luck with how long harry is gonna
stay sleeping i can't believe i've
gotten honestly me too we're at like an
hour and 15 minutes yeah no it's any
moment now um okay so let's dive into
the real housewives of salt lake city
recap it's not going to take a long time
you think that people would prefer that
over on burning yourselves if something
has to get cut
unburden yourselves okay unburden
yourselves is brought to you by curology
i actually just got my third curology
package i've been on it for like over a
year now it's a game-changing custom
skincare made for you by a dermatology
provider so they'll create a custom
prescription cream for your specific
goals whether that's acne pores skin
texture dark spots fine lines
or something else you'll start by taking
a short online skin quiz and uploading
the photos and if it's a good fit
they'll ship you your formula right to
your door it even has your name on the
bottle i mean we all have such different
skin i don't know why we would all be
using the same products so curology is
just really the answer to everyone's
questions when it comes to their skin
like here are my problems here's my skin
texture here's my skin type give me a
custom formula like you and i jackie
have totally different skin there's no
reason why we should ever be using the
same skin care products so you can get
started with curology just like we did
with a 30 a free 30-day trial at
curology.com toast just pay five dollars
for shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash toast to
start your free 30-day trial you can
cancel any time and your prescription is
subject to consultation the consultation
is super in-depth they ask for like you
know really close up different angle
pictures of your skin a bunch of
different questions on your skin type
you have combination skin you have dry
skin you have oily skin it's really
in-depth it doesn't take that long and
then you know you're getting like a
really premium
really customized skin care
routine so that's curology.com toast pay
five dollars for shipping and handling
curology.com toast for your free 30-day
trial where you can cancel anytime okay
let's dive into unburden yourselves
which is our monday segment our new
segment where we feel like it is a safe
space for you to write in
tell us what you did this weekend that's
been giving you a pit on this monday we
can talk about it and then you can
officially unburden yourselves we're
gonna start off easy this one's small
but i actually know the feeling small
but mighty okay
small but mighty just like us
jackie and claudia
i feel awful
today was my 32nd wordle and i was at
the last one out of options so i googled
what the answer was i'm the worst
so i guess she's keeping her streak
she's 32 in a row
and she didn't want to lose her streak
so she cheated so you are a cheater i
just think it's important that you know
that but i actually am a really big
proponent of cheating because they
always say cheaters never win and
winners never cheat and i think that's
like the worst mantra we taught our kid
or like the youth because i've never
cheated and felt bad except i'm not
talking about like cheating on your
partner i'm talking about like cheating
in games changing life
yeah yeah but not on your partner like
no i'm not talking about that i'm a big
believer in cheating so i'm proud of you
you know what like you wanted your
streak and you found a way to get it
it's not cheating it's called being an
ingenue yeah no i love how in the same
episode where like work hard if you want
success
also cheat
no but sometimes i think success is a
lot about working hard cheating and luck
i i just want to say like cheating has a
bad stigma when sometimes like cheating
isn't bad i know like that sounds crazy
i just will never forget being at camp
as a kid and seeing that sign in the
dining hall
can't viega
winners never cheat and cheaters never
win and i was like damn that's powerful
and then the older i got and the more i
got away with cheating and the more i
benefited from like cheating on tests
and stuff i was like that is a dumb
[ __ ] sign
yeah well no that sign kind of makes
sense because if you cheated you
actually didn't win technically but i
think the saying cheaters never prosper
is untrue because
plenty of cheaters are prospering no and
like i cheated on the test and got away
with it and i'm therefore prospering and
then you could argue well you didn't
actually learn anything but here i am 20
years later not ever once having needed
the knowledge in which i cheated on so
who's really prospering now [ __ ] yeah i
think that when you cheat at things that
are like foolish to begin with such as
wordle yeah and especially new wordle
i've heard is
not the new york times has ruined it
concerning what i haven't wordled since
the day i went into the hospital because
i was hearing like the new york times
ruined it i was already like getting
that vibe and i was just like over it
and so i think when you cheat at stupid
[ __ ] like you play stupid games and you
win stupid prizes and that's what you
did with wordle 100
when you cheat on meaningful [ __ ] like
you're a piece of [ __ ]
yeah no of course like i agree with that
even though i did cheat on the sats and
i'm you know doing just fine
actually i don't feel like i should say
that it's like a board of education
going to come for me they take yeah no
seriously they take it really seriously
so that was a joke b.o.e i would never
cheat
okay next up
hello jack and claude i just have to say
this new segment has me dying this legit
just happened to me but i need to tell
someone and it's terrifyingly
embarrassing
before today i hadn't made a number two
in a couple days i have dulcolax
overnight that i ended up taking last
night when i got home from work fun fact
it didn't work when i wanted it to
fast forward to sitting in my office
today
when all of a sudden i get the sean
mendez sweats at my desk
i'm trying to finish up what i'm doing
so i can make it to the bathroom but
unfortunately i didn't make it the
squirts started coming out before i even
made it to the bathroom i don't think
i've ever heard noises like that come
out of my body i tried my best to clean
it up but i ended up being stuck in my
dirty pants for the rest of the day
luckily no one said anything to me but
i'm so embarrassed and i want to die and
i can never be seen around these people
ever again i think i have to quit i
think you have to quit too and there's
your solution i agree and i don't know
what episode we said this on but like we
literally just told you guys recently
like laxatives don't take them they
never work the way that you want them to
and i'm just in shock okay like if you
shot your pants in the workplace like go
home yeah finish out the work day like
what are you a cop like you have to be
there you work at an office you could go
home work from home and change your duty
pants yeah no like what is going on that
you can't just like take a sick day when
you have literally been sick in your
pants but i do have to say like there is
a lot to be learned here the first to be
learned is i think if you work out of
your home you should always in your desk
have a pair of pants and a fresh clean a
pair of underwear like you just never
know where life's gonna take you maybe
you get your period like yeah i think
having a fresh pair of undies
like you know what buy like just hanes
underwear on amazon have a chip to your
office and just throw it in your desk
you never know when you're going to need
a pair of underwear like
i'm just like
it's true like you never know but then
like then you're writing and saying my
co-worker found my underwear in my desk
and i have a pic better better than my
co-worker sniffed my duty from my pants
yeah i agree okay also another thing to
be learned here is like honestly i think
maybe you need to like take a few steps
away from your job because if you can't
even leave the office when you've taken
a literal dump in your pants i think you
have a toxic like relationship with work
no also and like again this is just like
bringing back to kim kardashian's quote
like you're working too hard now you're
working too hard
you're someone like you need to work a
little less and you need to have gone
home in that situation right unless like
it's your company i don't think anyone
needs to work that hard because at the
end of the day like it's just a job
yeah i guess it depends what the job was
like if you're the toll booth
conflicting today we are no but like
all of these like life is nuanced
nothing is the only thing that's true
what does a surgeon do if he's like mid
surgery and he gets the runs no that's
what i'm saying like there are some jobs
where you actually like can't go home
early in the middle of the day like but
an office job like there's nothing
you're doing at your office that you
can't do from your computer at home and
we learned that in covid right no i
agree and like if you were a toll booth
operator then no one's around you so
like
you could shut your pants
[Laughter]
that's true you really don't have
co-workers co-workers in your booth
right it's like a very socially distant
job yeah yeah yeah oh my god that is
beyond funny okay well you told us it's
over but learn from this okay there's a
lot to be learned keep underwear and
maybe have a healthier balance of work
and life and you guys don't take
laxatives
never that's the lesson they never work
the way they never work
yeah have a prune okay
have a prune here's the third and final
one oh my computer stop okay
we just went on a family trip to disney
the day before we left we were in epcot
and i drank around the world one too
many times i woke up that morning so
hungover oh my god that sounds like a
nightmare we drove to the airport i got
my seven month old out of the car and i
immediately pawned him off to another
family member saying i had to go pee
i ran into the airport at baggage claim
and i saw a family restroom i ran to it
and it was locked i looked around trying
to find another bathroom i saw it far
away i began running towards it and i
immediately puked i tried to hold it in
my hands but it went all over the floor
i looked around and it seemed like i was
alone i saw a water fountain went over
and washed my hands i left the puke on
the floor and then went back outside to
grab my seven month old and acted like
nothing happened by the way being hung
over at the airport with a baby is the
worst way to travel oh my god you just
left the vomit i guess that's better
than like people seeing you but like i
don't know you should have alerted like
a custodian or something because that's
like someone's job to clean it up
they'll find out soon enough
they didn't be alerted they have noses
yeah i mean
what you were sick like what could you
do
yeah no and you know what like throwing
up is like really
it happened i mean it's like because it
was hung over your hand you're hungover
like it's your fault it's not every
offense it's not like you were like sick
and
food poisoning this is like just like
julian real housewives of miami you know
like if you were like genuinely sick and
like you threw up like no one would
fault you but because you're like hung
over it's like a little bit of your feel
shitty yeah but like still in general
like you can't help where you throw up
and if you're just like vomiting like
that what can you do you're sick i don't
think there's anything
worse
than throwing up but i don't think
there's anything better than how you
feel afterwards like and i'm not talking
about hangover i'm talking about like
legitimately being ill or like food
poisoning or like nausea
it's crazy how amazing you feel
afterwards yes if you're legitimately
ill but like sometimes throwing up when
you're hungover makes you feel worse
because like you needed all of those
nutrients and things that were in your
belly and now i'm not talking about
hangover i'm just talking about like
nothing now have you ever been like food
poison like so nauseous sweating and
then you finally throw up it's like
heaven not in recent memory oh i ate at
philippe chow um and haven't been able
to eat there since because i got the
craziest food poisoning like both ends
me too from there over time really yeah
but like a really long time ago me too i
was still living at home because i
remember i was like throwing up in our
childhood bathroom i think they must
have changed their menu because now we
order from there sometimes and yeah it
took me years but i've eaten there there
somewhat recently
yeah so they got it together they
obviously knew but you know what if
throwing up on the floor and running
away is what this woman needed in order
to successfully travel with a baby then
you know what i respect that because
traveling with kids i i mean i've never
done it but i see other people in the
airport and like i always just like my
heart goes out to them that's gonna be
you no i know and i'm like i'm never
going anywhere again they're always for
clamped like trying to break down their
strollers like trying to throw the kid
in the babybjorn like i always just like
want to offer my help but like i can't
do anything you know the breaking down
of strollers and like the car seat
situation we actually have an amazing
stroller it's like not like glamorous or
anything and it's not that cute but it's
a stroller that becomes a car seat
without any extra parts necessary it's
called the duna and um
it's incredible i mean especially
because like we're like we need places
we don't have a car but like for being
in the airport it sounds ideal because
then you don't need to like carry a car
seat with you no i could just literally
like see you and zach trying to board
zach's trying to break down the stroller
like you're getting frustrated the kid
is getting fussy like i could just see
it like and that to me like when i have
a child i will not be leaving the state
for 10 years no that's my plan but zach
has gotten pretty good about like
breaking it down and stuff and that's
like that always reminds me of that
scene from um what to expect when like
all those dads have like they're locked
and loaded and like you need to have
like a training day with your partner
where they like get it down to under a
minute of doing all of the different
like
tasks contraptions
contraptions
okay so it appears as though first of
all that was unburdened yourselves thank
you to everyone who wrote in it appears
as though harry's still asleep so can we
really quickly talk about alexander yeah
yeah i can't believe he's been such a
good boy for his mommy you know he is a
king who respects podcasts
i also pumped while i um did my makeup
so if he were to like wake up and be
like i could use a snack um he has one
there's a bottle okay yeah so
finally we were put out of our misery
and i just can't help with comparing
this gen shaw situation to the erica
jane situation and to me if erica jane
at the reunion and just the overall
season got you know grilled at like a
level 10
then i think i'm being generous and
saying gen shaw has been given a level
four i was going to say 4-2
it's insane even like we got nothing
like i just feel like andy didn't give a
[ __ ] and you know she pulled a little
bit of the you know i can't talk about
it it's legal which is expected erica
did that too and i do believe erica was
being honest when she said
i legally can't talk about like she
tried to be as transparent because she
really had nothing to hide i think
um but with i think jen has like a lot
to hide and her not even being able to
answer like the most simplest of
questions which i think had nothing to
do with the legal system i just i've
never been more convinced than i am now
that jen
might be going to jail even though
one of the women i forget who it was
maybe it was whitney or heather did make
an interesting point because we've been
saying how stu took a plea plea deal as
and he pled guilty which obviously like
bodes terribly for jen but someone
offered a different perspective like oh
maybe that like clears jen she'll he'll
shoulder the burden and like and it was
him she you know he didn't know
she didn't know that she had this person
working for him who was being you know
illegal
yes well two i have two thoughts about
that one yet now her defense could be it
was all stu look at him he pled guilty
guilty other thought is that he probably
took a deal and shared information that
they will now use against jen that's
what i was thinking initially but i
hadn't thought of the other spin until i
think whitney or heather said it yeah it
could go either way and i guess
hopefully the truth will prevail i mean
when i watch like from the persons
like when we watch erica now watching
jen like i definitely do
skew more towards like giving them the
benefit of the doubt and like believing
what they're saying because i'm just
like i try to be like just a trusting
person and it seems like all of the
women like no one raised their hand that
they thought jen was guilty but again i
guess like why would you be friends with
someone who you think could do something
like this so like no but also if this is
your friend you would never believe that
they could do something like this
therefore like you would assume that
they are
the environment of this season hasn't
been one that even lends itself to like
being open to thinking jen did anything
wrong like everyone is just like jen's
in this even though you know who the
person who thinks
jen is the most guilty
it's heather and i think last night
really showcased heather in the worst
light possible
i think honestly she might be the
biggest loser to ever grace this show
because not only does she she was only
one who was like i don't care if jenna's
guilty or i'm i'm gonna be her friend
she brought up a thousand times and jen
was like stop bringing it up and
honestly heather should stop bringing up
how nasty and bad jen treated her and
how they're still friends now because it
makes heather look like the biggest
loser of all time like you're
acknowledging this person literally
couldn't have given less of a [ __ ] about
you and now you're gonna throw yourself
under the bus for them like heather i'm
sorry heather is the worst yeah no her
saying i don't care whether she did it
or not like i support her like
that's a really terrible take like you
should care whether she did those things
that she's accused of or not i mean the
fact that i understand that they wait
till the end to like deal with this big
thing but i felt like with erica
throughout every part it came up a
little bit they dealt with it and then
they did like the whole meat and
potatoes at the end like with jen i felt
like by the time they got to her like
everyone was so over it it was probably
already like eight o'clock at night andy
was over it like there was really the
questions like kind of sucked and the
only question that i really wish that he
would ask her is like you say that you
are innocent you know and that you're
being like targeted but like how does
homeland security the fbi and the nypd
like
come to the conclusion that we're coming
for jen shaw like what do you think led
them to this and and where did they go
wrong like what have they gotten wrong
about this
right because the difference in erica
and jen's trials which are
so different one because it wasn't erica
i was erica's husband and this is jen
being accused not coach shaw um but the
other big difference is
the girardies were being sued by people
corporations
gen xiao is on trial with the u.s
government like they don't make mistakes
like if they're coming for you it's over
like they already know i don't think
there's a lot and maybe i'm wrong i
don't think that like the fbi and
homeland security
you know get people and then they get
off scot-free like that's just not
really how it works
yeah and i mean andy said like the
d.a the new york d.a gets you know
95 and jen had a really good answer for
that that's because people accept plea
deals aka stewart um
but yeah that's a good answer i don't
think that they like go to all of this
trouble on a whim
right so i just think like and by the
way her date has been pushed back it was
supposed to be like in two weeks and
it's been pushed back again
um which i don't know if that like
provides relief or like treacherousness
for jen like i'm sure she wants it over
with but she might be going to jail so
then you know she gets more time with
her kids i don't know um
yeah i
i'm not sure
yeah i don't know either it's just crazy
to me that like jan jensen's accused of
like these heinous crimes and yet like
lisa barlow had the worst union
experience lisa was held the most
accountable and i mean the the stuff
about like the meredith rant i i'm like
so sad about it because
me too i really like lisa and merida's
friendship and i think that they had a
real friendship and like be on the show
and i want meredith to forgive her but i
could never forgive her and meredith is
even more like
they want to say stubborn or she's like
so principled like meredith can't give
that like no i couldn't and so i i don't
know how they move forward from here
because like the things that she said in
the way that she said them
it's just unforgivable
i know but you know what's tough is like
and i'm not making a pass for it but
like you know we're all entitled to like
our own thoughts and our own privacy and
like she wasn't saying it to anyone she
didn't sit down on camera like she was
caught in like a moment of fury talking
to herself
um
and that's something no one's ever
supposed to hear and her and meredith
could have made up and moved on and like
she could have just you know harbored
those feelings in the moment but the
fact that like she was miked and we
really got this like intimate personal
scene like we really weren't not
supposed to see that just sucks because
like you know we all we all have people
we love but we all think things you know
we're entitled to our internal monologue
yeah that's actually a good point i
hadn't thought of it like that i was
kind of thinking of it like the way the
other women did which is like this is
what you really think this is who you
really are i don't know i'm more
realistic of human nature like we love
people but we have things to say about
them i know but so like
usually you don't find out what people
actually think it's in their brain
but now knowing now knowing what someone
thinks of you like how can you accept
them as a close friend you you can't and
meredith can't maybe whitney heather
could heather oh
these women are just out of control you
know what whitney and heather are so
atrocious they've actually made me feel
bad for lisa barlow which is not a
feeling i ever really thought that i
could feel yeah no like i don't really
have a horse in this race but um if i
did it's it wouldn't be
it's kind of like lisa barlow i mean i
think meredith is it's she's still my
number one for the most part but she
just um she's not so involved in the
day-to-day so she's disengaged yeah it's
really lisa for me and like when whitney
was like talking about how she like
found her voice i was like
lose it please i know i can't
immediately
no i can't with these women they're
they're atrocious it's just it was so it
was it was such a letdown of a season
disappointing and especially the reunion
i felt like all season we're like okay
but at the reunion the questions will be
asked vindication the feet will be held
to the fire and it was so [ __ ] shitty
yeah three parts of shittiness
a great 100 it was atrocious and i'm
so relieved it's over does that mean
yeah what's coming back soon i mean new
york is like gone
yeah new york is gone
dumois posted something today yes and um
i need to talk about why it's not the
society but please share what you think
they that they post in okay so somebody
who obviously gives jamaa tips wrote
huge news about a beloved show with an
ensemble cast on a major streamer coming
soon it's coming back
it first aired in 2019 and the
announcement is coming in a few people
will be thrilled about this one why do
you not think it's a society oh okay
sorry i didn't see that it said it first
aired in 2019. i didn't think it was a
society because of a show with a beloved
cast that gives me like frasier vibes
yeah no me too but it says she respond
dumas said can you give a hint around
this time it first aired
the person responded 2019. oh my god i
think that's it then i think that's a
two major streamer even though the cast
is like not beloved because like they
were all relatively unknown but it's
possible but like the show is beloved so
maybe they just got confused yeah so
i will
literally
die and by the way i will 100 take
credit for the show coming back
yeah no i think we we could say that we
had a big part in that i'm not gonna get
my hopes up
but i'm feeling more hopeful than when i
saw your story initially i don't know
how i miss hot that's okay um you're
busy i'm just being a child being a mom
no yeah like everything is just like
different now like the time that i have
the energy that i give
toward things and like even just the way
i consume instagram stories it's just
like tap tap tap i mean you were doing
that to me before so nothing has really
changed for me um no i mean you know
when i i love when you use captions
actually sometimes i do tap because also
like i talk to you all day every day
there's nothing that you say on your
instagram stories that you haven't
already said to me on facetime so mean
okay well that is our first show back um
jackie thank you for taking 90 whole
minutes this has been the longest
episode oh yeah 90. wow yeah wow so
we love you
we'll see you again a week from today
but there will be episodes all of this
week with different co-hosts make sure
you're keeping up on the toast instagram
for updates you're with me again next
monday i think maybe the next monday
after that but then the week after that
you're on tuesday like we try and keep
you in the beginning of the week but
just make sure to keep up on the toast
instagram every week for the schedule
yes exactly i'm looking forward to
seeing more of the schedule and i'm so
excited for your week of um toast and
friends it's going to be so premium
so see you in a week and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe oh
wait the morningtoes instagram is back
yes
it like literally took months and we we
told you guys that we would tell you
what happened but due to unforeseen
circumstances we actually can't tell you
just be happy that it's back
and thank you so much for listening to
the morning tell us the morning morning
show where we deliver the best life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtubes if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up come on we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio cast box all
the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us morning just leave a
five star review about our beautiful
stunning and smart we are the society
season two might be coming back and now
that the mornington's instagram is back
we can officially reinstate the morning
to season two so if you have made it to
the end of this episode and you want to
prove that you're better than all the
other toasters because you actually
listened to the end why don't you drop
an instagram an emoji on our most recent
instagram post perhaps a picture of a
babe
have a great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow
love ya bye